[Music]
oh yes my newest dot that was an 11 year
old kirsten dunst in the 1994 classic
interview with a vampire opposite Tom
Cruise and Brad Pitt no big deal can you
believe this movie turns 25 this year
easy way et was there from the beginning
so last night we surprised Kirsten with
a little class from her vampire past
Kirsten had a lot of screen time with
both Tom and Brad and we showed her what
she said back in the day about this
infamous kiss I hated it so much because
I don't know Brad was like my older
brother on the scent it's kind of like
kissing your brother I could help it I
know we're kissing an older guy when I
had kids my whole lips so as gross they
were so sweet to me I mean listen that
production that film was like nothing
else I've ever experienced they just
don't make movies like that Mac then
Brad was very impressed by his young
co-star but admits that kissing scene
was tough and comes this little woman
you know who ran circles around most of
the adults on the set she said the
hardest part was kissing you
listen was no easy road from Kirsten's
now 37 and a mom to a baby boy in her
new Showtime series on becoming a God in
Central Florida she has a make under
with that big hair fake tan and braces
the braces were just little clip-ons but
the spray tan was every Sunday night for
six months and then you have to sleep in
it so I always had like brown sheets in
the morning and couldn't hold my baby at
night if I get spray tan on it
Kirsten plays a woman who gets involved
in a cult like pyramid scheme
I can recruit talk about a cool boss
this show is from George Clooney's
company so does Clooney micromanage
actually George
let us do it Hey they are part of the
process burns at very beginning and then
[Music]